hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong it's your girl
Jacqueline back again with my lovely
co-host Mr Mark Ellis lovely's the word
Jacqueline I mean should we call you
handsome I could say handsome no I don't
pull off handsome lovely I'll take I'll
take a rugged you know you know rugged
but if you're talking about the king of
rugged it's probably the star of the
movie yeah that we have on hand today
because I mean the star of the movie
that we're talking about isn't here no
he is not here but he does uh he does
personify rugged yes we're talking about
a man who really does need no
introduction but before we get to him I
want to make sure his opening act get
ready
absolutely seriously I want to make sure
that we know we have an incredible guest
with us today of course I'm talking
about Candace Cruz she's an actor on air
host Candace is an entertainment expert
for mbclx I want to say Excel every time
I see it Candace welcome thank you for
having me I mean can I actually be his
opening act please I mean I think he's a
good guy to go ahead of I mean
especially if his ending is this is
Sparta but if he says Angel has fallen
too I would honestly be here a lot of
these movies like a lot of stuff gets
blown up and destroyed so you probably
do want to go before Gerard Butler and
not after Gerard Butler yes yeah and
he's got a Trilogy of movies and we're
talk we're celebrating what I I'm just
gonna put this out there now I think
that the movie we're talking about today
is the best of said Trilogy you think
it's the best I've said Trilogy I don't
think that the Tomato Meter agrees with
either one of y'all but then it's wrong
Jacqueline but that is what we're here
to discussed today that's right folks
we're talking about the 2019 classic
film Angel has fallen 39 rotten on the
Tomato Meter but it has a 93 audience
score if there was ever a time for folks
to be divided it is definitely out on
this we were talking about this because
Mr Gerard Butler the man that
personifies the uh moniker rugged has
another film coming out playing on
January 3rd 13th if it's Gerard Butler
and they're blowing stuff up you might
find me there but we're going to talk
about this one also we want to give a
shout out to our Gerard Butler guide on
Rotten Tomatoes at editorial that's
where you can find all of his films
ranked from top to bottom and also RT
Essentials Gerard Butler you can find
that our Ott channels and on YouTube
before we get there though I want to go
ahead and have
um this person next to me give this
great synopsis because let me guess and
this is not saying that I haven't
watched the film I have but I'm just
gonna go ahead and guess something has
fallen
but I will let you go ahead and give us
this announcement do I know that's
something that's Fallen is the sky it's
it's all going to crap folks luckily we
have Mike Banning who is the secret
service agent former secret service
agent played by Gerard Butler here he is
uh he's sort of implicated in a failed
assassination attempt he has to escape
from that then he's got to escape the
FBI and so basically every government
agency is looking for this guy but he is
on a desperate mission to uncover the
truth luckily it's not just him because
we also have is everybody sitting down
is everybody prepared yeah oh man Nick
Nolte shows up it's amazing Danny
Houston's in here you get a little bit
of uh Morgan Freeman so this is just a
such a fun movie and it is the
culmination of Olympus Has Fallen where
the White House is sort of being taken
over that's like the code for the White
House is being taken over I guess and
then London has fallen and London is
another place in the world that's
important so we had to go stop back
another kidnapping but this time instead
of the White House it's like the Tower
of London and Kensington Palace and over
there I remember Angela Bassett being
great in that movie yes and she was
great in both yeah yeah and uh and I
don't remember much else about London is
fun I remember London has fallen being
like all right and I don't need I don't
know that we're gonna get any more of
these and then we got Angel has fallen
redeemed themselves thank you because I
would say Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I'll
kick off that round table I'm gonna say
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong is that this
should be a fresh movie because what do
you go see this movie for you want a lot
of Slam bang action some Ridiculousness
sure but Gerard Butler's great he can
carry an action movie asleep and he's
wide awake in this and I really had fun
with all the twists and turns the
explosions Nick Nolte's in it come on
Nick Nolte's in it really is the tagline
for this movie and all we need Nick
Nolte's in it that's all we need like my
tickets bought Nick Nolte's in it but
but before we go too far I definitely
want to make sure Candace you tell me
specifically is is Rotten Tomatoes wrong
and you could give me a brief reason why
but we'll just leave it at that is
Rotten Tomatoes wrong about Angela's
falling at 39 rotten hands down the
audience had it right they flipped the
numbers
hello I mean it is a standalone film
Mark and I were talking about this
before is that I watched this one first
and was like oh there's oh there okay I
don't really need to watch the others I
did but they were kind of okay they were
like every other White House movie that
everything's fallen and you got to save
the president you save the president end
of story but this one there was so much
more to it and people have obviously
fallen in love with Gerard Butler in all
of his movies and fall in love with Mike
Banning
um and I this the cast alone I thought
the story was solid it was awesome it
was solid
I really tried to find holes to poke
into and I was like there's none there
there's none you see it's a solid action
movie Nick Nolte plugs all homes I would
say solid does not a recommendation in
their lie but I will give you solid is
better than the score that has been
given all right what about you where do
you fall on this one very wrong should
be fresh
um this is not a this is not hard
um this is this is a very easy I think
this is probably the freshest of the
group because when Olympus Has Fallen I
was like that's a really great premise
and I like the movie I thought it was
better than it's the the movie released
later that year that was very similar
White House Down I thought the Olympus
Has Fallen is better one in his Pawn I
was like ah or whatever but Angela's
Fallen just it's exactly what I wanted
in an action movie where I just get to
stuff a bunch of popcorn in my face and
root for somebody who's relatable and
we've seen this kind of movie before
it's been done in Mission Impossible
movies where it's not just one agency
it's every government agency that's all
running after you and maybe you can
trust one or two other people and that's
our mission if feels impossible not for
the rugged handsomeness of Gerard Butler
it's interesting you say the rugged
handsomeness that there isn't every man
quality of Gerard Butler which I will
say for everything that I do like about
this film it very much lies in his
Everyman but how many movies is it's
like this is Gerard Butler and he is
just like the best version of a confused
Dad yes that any of these situations
could call for just doing that and
that's great but he's still essentially
playing the same role over and over and
over again and I think that's the issue
I have with both this movie and maybe
why it has the score that it has because
I think into the first Olympus Has
Fallen which I actually watched first
and did really enjoy okay I barely do
remember also London has fallen I do
remember it I think more than Mark we're
such American we are there's another
country it's something we don't care I
watched it though but the kicker I will
say about it is that I think Angel has
fallen even under its best and most like
positive aspirations I cannot make this
movie go over 55. really it's not
because in the back of my mind it is
still the same movie it does not do
anything different it's great in the
sense that it's a new style of it yeah
it is definitely a new setting it is
definitely a new premise it's
essentially like yeah they put these
folks in a different house and the house
is built differently than the first two
but we are still doing the same things
look we're all dancing around this issue
okay Die Hard is like the best yeah you
know sort of action movie of all time
slash Christmas movie and and the first
three movies are are a Trilogy right and
and they're a wonderful trilogy but
again it's like John McLean even says it
how many times can the same stuff happen
to the same guy how can the same they
have the same guy twice so if this is
like the lower Red version of Die Hard
yes then I think it then you look at
Gerard Butler is like that every man
that's not quite as relatable or as
charismatic as Bruce Willis in his prime
but he's damn close and so if you can't
get new Die Hard movies which they've
tried and they haven't been good true
I'll take the Fallen franchise and I
will say that is the part of this that
that that sort of like the glue that
holds it all together is the fact that
that Jared Butler is our new version of
John McLean he's not as smart he's not
as cool but he's still the guy that you
want to see make it to the end and so
that's the reason why I'm like is again
I'm gonna be this person again it's
wrong-ish it ain't that wrong it ain't
that wrong
like Gerard Butler has a lot of skills
he's got a lot of talents aren't you
impressed though that like not all of
them are on display in this movie no and
also when Gerard Butler comes on screen
in this movie he's not as young he's not
as handsome he does look like me and the
character has ailments yes the
characters he's lived a life you can see
it on his face and you're like okay
but then that gives me even more
affirmation of why this is a cool movie
you can still do that crap I can look at
him don't do that and I'm like I could
do that yeah cause like I'm I was
probably hungover when I saw the movie
in theaters and I'm like this guy's
clearly been through many hangovers I
can relate to this guy all I see in this
movie is I'm like man alcohol really is
a carcinogen yes oh yes yes and you see
it on his face and also I will say too
um we talked about this we're going to
go into movie talk um we'll go ahead and
go into two minutes Tim but we
definitely talked about this you can
watch this series and definitely see uh
Jared Butler just slowly let himself a
little bit go just a little like just
just say you know what he saved the
president he saved parts of London he
saved two presidents he doesn't need to
save himself for the gym you're right he
doesn't need to save I'm not trying to
body shame the man I'm just saying you
can tell that he was not as invested in
the physical aspect of the performance
he's not 300 the latter part of the
series that's all I will say I was in
300 and I had those ABS I would never
work out another day I'd be like I'm in
the Hall of Fame you would just let them
go and I think he did that because
they're never even attempted since then
there's a certain point you get to at
the gym where I want to go up to like
some dudes I work out with and I'm like
hey you won
now here's your trophy you just retire
let us all catch up yeah save some room
for the rest of us you can baby and me
I'm like the Hamilton song I will never
be satisfied I'm joking I I am very
satisfied you all this is the visual
medium you know I am very she looks
great doesn't she shut up shut up we're
gonna go ahead and go to another part of
this visual medium we're gonna go to our
favorite segment two minutes with Tim
[Music]
here's a quick overview of the has
fallen franchise to date critics found
Olympus Has Fallen to be a reasonably
entertaining action thriller in the Die
Hard Mode critics found London has
fallen to be substantially more generic
and substantially more jingoistic
critics found Angel has fallen to be
right in the middle solid if
unspectacular action flick with a decent
sense of humor and a strong supporting
turn from Nick Nolte Angel has fallen as
rotten to 39 on the Tomato Meter with
191 reviews and it has a 93 audience
score and just for comparison Olympus
Has Fallen from 2013 is rotten at 50 and
London has fallen from 2016 is rotten at
27 in a rap review Soren Anderson of the
Seattle Times wrote Angela's Fallen
plays out exactly as you would expect
from a pot boiler of this type no
surprises here other than that it exists
at all however in a fresh review Mick
LaSalle of the San Francisco Chronicle
wrote Butler can do more but he's so
good at doing this one thing that it has
become his brand that might be a
blessing and a curse but if it's a curse
there are worse curses the Rotten
Tomatoes critics consensus reads cut
from the same rough cloth as its
predecessors Angel has fallen rounds out
a mostly forgettable action Trilogy in
fittingly mediocre fashion so that's
Angela's fallen and a brief overview of
the has fallen movies back to you folks
before we talk any more about what Tim
said there because he gave us a lot to
chew on let's go ahead and throw it to
movie talk
I like how he said it's cut from the
same uh cloth that's literally what
threw me is like he was getting
Shakespearean and his two minutes but he
said cloth and I started to think well
okay what's tougher than cloth like
chainmail but then I was like oh isn't
cheesecloth something that like I think
cheese cheese sauce yeah it's like a
thing you clean I'm not a I don't know
how to clean anything but I think
cheesecloth it's like a rougher more
tumble cloth it is but also when you
talk about cheese some people would say
that this is a Cheesy movie I don't
agree with that I enjoy cheese and I
celebrate cheese but I feel like cheese
cloth would be an accurate description
for this movie I'm gonna go burlap okay
strangers yeah yes okay like like uh
okay like Sam what is his name scarecrow
whatever he oh yes yeah whatever that is
this is so Random uh like let me just go
live in my Homestead of dreams right
here first first let's go ahead and
clear this up because this is a
franchise and although we're not talking
about the whole franchise we do have to
go ahead and say Mark is this the best
one yes this is the best one of the
three because I think it's you like
seeing Olympus Has Fallen because that's
more of a simple premise where okay uh
Something's Happened at the White House
we need to go stop it but I sort of like
when action movies are able to go
completely bad right and they're like oh
this is happening then this is happening
and everybody thinks I did it and we
somehow are able to weave that into like
a somewhat cohesive narrative they think
this movie pulls off and in between get
a lot of action set pieces so yes you do
need some additional Firepower luckily
Nick Nolte does show up as Mike
Manning's dad for some reason who's also
an explosives expert you get Morgan
Freeman in this but the thing that sells
me on it is there's is like this weird
backstory that you pick up on between
Mike Banning Gerard Butler's character
and Danny Houston's character they
clearly have worked together before and
it's one of my favorite scenes in the
movie is up top where it's like they're
still buddies and and and Mike is kind
of showing everybody the ropes on this
training course but then Danny Houston
like wants to have a drink with them or
wants to have dinner with them and it's
like wait a minute I don't trust this I
don't trust what this guy's motives are
compounded by the fact that it's Danny
Houston playing it and as much as I love
Danny Houston I'm sure he's a sweetheart
in person you can't trust that guy too
much in movies every movie he shows up
to and you're like who are you going to
betray first of course you know what's
what's great about this is the beginning
of the movie Gerard Butler basically
plays James Bond any time he's anywhere
and this is like the lighter or like uh
Robbie um that played Hagrid uh that
actor
Coltrane played this version and golden
eye you know what I mean uh you had the
um the Spanish guy in Skyfall plays his
characters the character you need to
trust but you don't want to the the
pseudo like that guy I don't disagree
with him that's also what makes me feel
like these are James Bond movies they
just always have the same setup but
Gerard Butler is no James Bond yes but
I love him but let's wow
that was love okay I was literally about
to say this is the James Bond movie in
the sense that that's what the premise
they're setting up but this is not him
but do you think this is his best
version of what he does in this series
because that was my question I was gonna
bring to you is yeah is this the best of
what Jared Butler is I'm thinking this
might be for you you don't seem a big
fan I think I mean I think out of all
three yes hands down because I think
this has more like you were talking
about there's an underlying story that
is more so than bang them up shoot him
up movies that we always see like the
White House is coming down the president
we got it got it but the story between
the two
um that have come prior to they have
their past they serve together and even
the nuances of just the looks at the end
like when that's the final like Showdown
and he even looks at him he's sitting
down with him on the floor while he dies
and says I'm glad it was you like
there's so much undertone to it that it
gives a little bit more heart to an
action film so I think maybe that's why
I like it so much more is this this is
not just on this series but like of all
how much Gerard Butler have you seen I
should ask but of all the Gerard Butler
have you seen is this still the Pinnacle
no no I love PS I love you and Phantom
of the operas okay I'm a rom-com fan but
I love that he's branched out into this
action world after 300 and like the bang
him up shoot him up I guess is what I
like to always call them
too he was always good that was
ridiculous but I still enjoyed watching
them gerardball is just watchable and so
the one that he did with Kevin Love
Michael that's the awesome truth yeah
yeah yes it's not a good movie but I
still enjoyed watching I liked it well
the original the awful lot I think it's
1963 off the truth that I think is uh
don't don't quote me on those incentive
files but I think it's Cary Grant don't
don't quote me on this one but the
original Awful Truth is amazing uh I
wish you would have seen the Ugly Truth
or the awful Ugly Truth is the ugly
truthful truth Ugly Truth the original
Ugly Truth is much better than this one
and and he's also great as uh as the one
of the primary voices in the How to
Train Your Dragon movies oh my gosh it's
like when you look at his Tomato Meter
it's like oh yeah he's in like like
denim of Thieves and all this stuff but
it's like oh right he's the dad and how
to train your dragons is another one so
I will just say this Pinnacle of Gerard
Butler being an action star 300. yeah
nickel of Gerard Butler doing anything
else Phantom of the Opera the movie that
Gerard Butler does that I wish more
people would watch and appreciate him
for is the dragon ones because I had
forgotten about that how to train your
dragon forgot about it those movies when
you talk about the great trilogies of
all time and I'm putting all time up
there oh wow I'll put classic Star Wars
I'll put the Lord of the Rings uh you
know Back to the Future the first one is
so good I think it helps carry the other
two uh but How to Train Your Dragon
movies like The Toy Story movies yeah
we're just talking animated so I put How
to Train Your Dragon up there with any
of it and Gerard Butler is great as as
lending that sort of fatherly you know
he can be imposing but he can also have
a heart and you don't see as much of
that here but you see a little bit of it
like there's something about it and it
might factor in with dudes more than
anybody else is when we go see an action
movie we do want a character we can
relate to you know we we want a
character we can either aspire to be
which is why Schwarzenegger and Stallone
were so big in the 80s and 90s is
because oh I want a body like that yeah
but I think that from die hard and then
into some other movies like The Rock
where Nick was cage just gets thrown
into this scenario and then we have
Gerard Butler's of the world come up
it's like oh I actually believe I could
do that you know I can't and I actually
don't look like Gerard Butler but I'm
like I know he's wearing a shirt I wear
a shirt like that I could pull that off
yeah hey look in that sort of like
representation matter
for white guys like myself even even
even sloppy straight white boys like me
I'm not saying that that was you you're
not on the schlubby side but that's who
that Avatar is oh trust me it's
definitely going after this last holiday
season I can get schwabby real quick I
have never heard that word before that's
a new one for me yeah I mean I just say
it oh good now you'll always associate
the term schlubby with Marco I would say
nah I would say Mark is very far from a
dad bod he is being very generous on
that one but this is who the Avatar is
to represent yeah I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna say great great summation of my
long-winded diatribe Gerard Butler's all
of our avatars
and it's not a bad one to have I would
just say this is still a man that gets
thirsted I will say this okay so I'm
gonna put a little bit of homework so
I'm gonna go tomorrow because I feel
like if I put you on the spot right now
you're gonna be like girl really you're
gonna make me do math
so give me your favorite rated at about
60 on the Tomato Meter movie which movie
do you have in that sort of range that
you love as as far as like action movies
or I have an action movie any movie I'll
try to keep it in that sort of genre
that we're talking about and it would
probably be a Van Damme movie with it's
like a hard target something like that
where again you realize that this is
very like highly stylized action but the
way it's shot and it's just so it's so
cool to watch the action sequences which
you also get an angel is following yeah
but also say like if you're looking to
Die Hard sort of knockoffs yeah there
was a slew of them the early 90s were
fun they were we got a lot of Die Hard
knockers Under Siege was great and I
think that's probably higher than 60
percent
yeah uh the Van Damme movie sudden death
where it's a die hard at a hockey game
where this is like game seven of the
Stanley Cup finals and Van Damme's kid
really wants to go and he plays a
firefighter and wouldn't you know Powers
Booth is gonna hold the entire Arena
hostage luckily Van Damme is there he
plays he sneaks into the goalie uniform
at one point amazing amazing movie I dig
that one okay so do you have a movie
around that range or it's like it's just
barely sort of fresh-ish that you like
like the more cheesier
movie that you like that's in that range
because what I was going to ask Mark is
give me the reason why Olympus Has
Fallen should rank above that hard
target well because this is the thing
like why should this be fresh because I
could honestly say I think this movie is
better than its score absolutely I would
be hard-pressed to say it's better than
the last dragon which is my action movie
that's around 50 to 60 that's cheesy and
I'm gonna put it in a context like this
then I think that there's a there's a
demographic of people especially around
the holiday season that cannot get
enough of holiday movies and it doesn't
really matter the quality of it is
perfect example because you could
probably watch a all-time Christmas
movie you know you could put It's a
Wonderful Life you do a modern home
alone L something like that but you
could also put on anything that Hallmark
puts out and be like oh this is just my
comfort holiday movie food so I can do
action movies I think maybe my appetite
for watching an action movie like this
they can feel reductionist and can feel
sort of the same as what we've just seen
as all of its predecessors but it still
is different enough and it makes me feel
the comfort that I'm seeking from an
action movie so is Angel has fallen
better than Hard Target ah I can't but
you can say that it's fresh but I also
think heart Target's very fresh so oh
God I think action movies are like my if
you don't want to pick the movie yeah
just imagine your mind what what makes
this one compelling to be a fresh movie
I got like that I did that logic though
all right what makes this compelling you
know I was re-watching it again this
morning and I watched it like a couple
weeks ago and I was like really trying
to find holes to put in it because for
me I love this genre of movie but it's
not my go-to my go-to is always like a
rom-com or fantasy so when I watch these
most of the time they are all pretty
much the same track you have someone
kidnapped you have to beat all the bad
guys shoot everything up there's a lot
of explosions there's not really a story
line and then that's the end of it this
one to me had multiple story lines so I
think that that's why I loved it so much
and the father-son yeah father son the
the wife not really knowing his
backstory and having the Friendship come
back and really getting to know him more
on a different level being a father now
he's on the verge of death because now
he's going to the doctor and finding out
that he has problems that are not
probably going to be resolved then
you've got a president that he's friends
with that he has a relationship with
like there's so many different story
Lines within it that I feel like it
supersedes
um a lot of other action movies to me
okay I think those are all
compelling enough but I just I still
come out there still not coming this is
what I would say
um this movie got smaller in a lot of
ways which allowed so many other things
to get heightened like the performances
like especially Nick Nolte like he's
he's just chewing every bit of scenery
like you may not know he's in a movie
you know what I mean that he can
possibly do
um we're just at his house for that
scene
um but there's not a single aspect of it
that I found to be particularly Mark
noteworthy okay you know what I'm saying
and I feel like if I'm gonna say that a
film is fresh I have to at least to
point to one thing and it can be like
the smallest of things like it can be
something as simple as you know the
heart that's behind die hard if nothing
else there was there there's like a real
heart and emotional resonance to die
hard that elevates it above every other
action movie that did everything else
that it does right I watched a lot of
action movies I I still haven't been
able to put my finger on exactly why
this is true I don't know why the die
hards the first three die hards are
great in my opinion including die hard
2. and then Live Free or Die Hard and A
Good Day to Die Hard no thank you but
somehow you mentioned James Bond earlier
we always get excited for new James Bond
Adventures even though they're all the
same and we always get excited for a new
Mission Impossible movie even though
they're all the same like this so both
of those movies do a very good job of
making sure that the emotional resonance
behind it is never cheap there is this
was a movie that tried to make a cheap
oh emotional okay okay Candace is
talking about didn't hit didn't hit home
with you because it felt artificial
everything about this felt artifact why
are you swaying me right now this is not
okay
I didn't do what they needed to do in
fact they did do what they need to do
and that's what you guys found this was
the thing if it's gonna be a movie that
I have to at least point to Fresh I got
to be like okay yeah they did it but
they did this not just like exceptional
I don't need you to give me the Steven
Spielberg tracking shot but I need to
see some aspect of his storytelling the
cinema the performances whatever that
really marked it the biggest thing about
this is it seemed they got actors that
wanted to just chew the scenery that
does not really that happens in a trauma
movie that's not that doesn't really
like kick this one apart and the thing
that they could have done well they
really kind of mailed in
what could they have done well the the
emotional resonance behind this to
actually drive the story it just felt so
forced everything that was about emotion
of why these people are here what they
care about all of that stuff felt so
contrived well and the whole thing is
contrived I'm not trying to pretend that
it's not right but like give me
something I feel like I can forgive some
of it because it like with a movie like
that I think it's a somewhere in horror
movies like we talked about Bride of
Chucky last week where you know is it
the best move I've ever seen no but
you're willing to forgive some aspects
of it because you're having such a good
time
you're you're you you found this one
character that you can kind of go on to
and with this I think with every new
action set piece that we get an angel
has fallen even more so than Olympus in
London there's somebody else involved
and there's like a new player and it's
and it's always like refreshing and
that's why my favorite scene in this
movie is where we get to meet Nick Nolte
and all of his explosive wonders
yeah yes it was just like this guy's
been preparing for this he was ready
longer than Jamie Lee Curtis has been
preparing for the return of Michael
Myers he's been training for this for no
less than 40 years and he people thought
he was crazy and guess what he wasn't
crazy but can I ask you a question
though you were saying that it felt
superficial what Story Land of all the
ones that I said would have been the one
that needed to go deeper not it's not
about needed to go deeper it was like
this movie is a movie that makes you
turn off your brain and enjoy it yes
when I keep seeing these contrivances I
just keep being like it feels like a
sweater that itches it's like yeah this
is a sweater and I'm in it but it's
ignore the itch long enough it's still
comfortable but it's still itchy it's
still itchy you just can't think about
it
makes sense I do not believe for one
second that this is you know what I mean
like you need to do what Candace and I
did because Candace and I wore this like
a t-shirt and now they make t-shirts I
love how they they manufacture clothing
now because you put on a T-shirt and you
just rip the tag off back in the day in
the older you had to get out scissors
and you had to cut it and sometimes you
didn't cut the tag right it would be
worse ripped the tag off I ripped the
tag off going into this move and again
this was not a movie where it's the
movie's fault it's not even the movies
fault because the very first one is the
one that I would have given the highest
score ever this movie did not have that
benefit and so by the time it got there
it's like this is a movie where this
needed to be the first time you saw it
for you to love it as much I think but I
did see it for the first time so maybe
that's why I love it because I saw this
one first out of sequence it's funny
because I had one of our friends at
Rotten Tomatoes edrick uh I was telling
him when I was shooting something else
in studio and he was asking me like oh
yeah so Angel was falling like do I need
to see the other two and I was like you
do nothing no no I don't even know there
were other fallens and then I looked and
I was like oh there's other fallens I
guess I should watch them yeah sure if
this movie was the only one I would give
it an entire different rating I would
actually be with you guys too to be like
you know what it probably needs to be
fresh yeah if you're doing it a third
time like this like I don't know it
feels like honestly it feels like late
seasons of certain shows like when they
repeat storylines can I tell you
something to get excited for that well
maybe okay
oh we may not just have three movies yes
we may have uh the rumor titles Knight
has fallen yes and I don't know how far
along we are I don't know if this is
actually in reality or if I'm just
trying to speak it into existence but
it's fairly soon I think the impressive
thing about if we get Knight has fallen
then we got this Trilogy is that I'm
taking this the other way where if you
compare this to the die hards of the
world in the mission impossible James
Bond maybe it doesn't hold up but
there's a number of movies that just go
direct to VOD with Big Time stars or
maybe of yesteryear you know Nick Cage
was doing that forever Wills was doing
that forever travolt is doing that
forever it's pretty impressive to see
the staying power of Gerard Butler in a
movie theater and still be able to pull
some numbers because if you look at the
box office for these movies they do
pretty well the worldwide grows for
Angel's Fallen 147 million dollars off a
budget of 40 million dollars which means
you get to make another movie hopefully
not his fault um but all of these movies
have done boffo box office they have
combined grossed over 500 million
dollars worldwide and the total budget
for all three combined is 170 million
dollars so now they're turning to profit
and now they're making them for 40.
which is another thing that I thought
was interesting with Angela's fallen for
the fact that it the price got lower
they definitely didn't lose a ton
because they just made it smaller they
made it more you know obviously you're
trying to get to Nick Nolte and then
it's like you know two men in a room
at it yeah it's also nice to have all
the sets that you made from the first
two if you need to yes because exactly
the first one costs the most to make and
I'm willing to bet recreating the White
House ain't cheap yeah exactly or you
know maybe reuse footage you never know
they do do that at times as well I
wanted to also to ask you about this one
Miss Cruz because this is the other part
of it that I think is a little bit
interesting in the sense where you may
think better or worse for it okay are
all the scenes that you love
do you love them ironically or do you
love them as they are
[Music]
do you really like some scenes to one of
my favorite scenes that I love in the
movie Elvis is I love it ironically and
it's the scene where like they they see
him playing and they like zoom in on it
and it's like he's why I cannot tell you
the reason why I like that movie is
because it was a cinematic moment I
laughed at it because it's a bunch of
white people screaming he's white really
hilarious thing in the world yeah so I
love that scene ironically yeah there's
a ton of those scenes in Olympus and
Angel has fallen excuse me so are all of
them like give me your ironic best scene
or maybe your best scene overall oh
because there are scenes like that in
this movie where it's like
dude like it's just the comical amount
of guns he has it's the comic book yes
it's the comical way that Jared Butler
like and one of the moments he's like
you know I'm too old for this crap like
trying to dodge stuff you know like well
yeah because he should have been hit
multiple guys exactly multiple times
that where that man should have died
exactly I mean someone's gun was just
empty in that one opportune moment
Energizer Bunny type stuff that happens
to him you laughing when this person oh
yeah his gun pops now his gun can't
shoot now that I crack up he's just
compare Gerard Butler to the Energizer
Bunny I mean I feel like he's at the end
of that Energizer Bunny but yeah he's
still he's still going
um
I think as is I don't think there was
too much I mean maybe I'm missing it but
I don't think there's too much irony I
feel like it's very Point Blank for what
it is even more like if you enjoy it
ironically like this is absurd and campy
and so therefore you're laughing at how
absurd and can't be this is Nick Nolte
when he's pulling all of his traps in
the woods not alone it's just like what
yeah it's heightened it's like wait this
guy is then there's more there's another
one and another one nothing but time on
his hand thank you
I'm interested to watch this movie again
and maybe like 10 years and just kind of
think about what you said as far as
enjoying and leaning into the the
hilarious ironical nature some of this
because for instance Hard Target is a
movie like that for me because John Wu
directed it and he loves his slo-mo and
he loves his like epic sort of hero
shots and Van Damme wanted all of those
in the movie so there's one scene in
hard target where he it doesn't get the
the the the the the crew job that he
wanted and so now he's gonna help this
girl look for a dad around New Orleans
and there's a bunch of barrels that are
slowly being moved out of the way she's
parked waiting for the barrels to move
and as soon as the barrels move it's Van
Damme yeah and it's just like the
slowest motion walk and it's like what
are we doing here yeah but for when I
saw it in eighth grade I was like this
is the greatest thing I've ever seen so
I'm interested to see it again but I
don't think that I but I think that
action movies day have taken a cue from
all they've stood on the shoulders
they've done what Jeff Goldblum says you
should not do in Jurassic Park and
they've looked and they've studied from
those and they've sort of looked at game
film like you would if you just played a
game you're like we can clean that up a
little bit I think that there's less
stuff to like laugh out loud at and more
it's just like you're kind of chuckling
I'm replaying in my head trying to think
of it yeah we're in on the joke I'm not
by any means pretending that we're not
but it's the absurdity of the Energizer
Bunny yeah this guy continues to do what
he does like again just the absurdity of
them being in the same situation I think
there's a line in this movie where it's
like not again where he's like basically
everyone yeah you know what I mean I
like when they do that though
exactly and then it keeps somehow
um supporting the other guy's plan yes
by him getting escaping they should be
like oh well he's escaped shouldn't we
be more on his side than the other no
point no and I and I will say okay the
movie is also in on these jokes because
of the part that I like on this one
because again this was the movie that we
assumed there would be no Morgan Freeman
right right and that was the other
reason why I think this one even took me
I know I watched this on Netflix I know
I did not like go to the theater watch
this this was definitely a Netflix
um
but that was a great moment for it too
and that also I think proves their whole
thing just because of how they do that
scene and that's like one of my favorite
ones at the end of there but it's almost
like they're breaking the fourth wall
exactly looking at the camera and being
like well that was wacky but like when
they say stuff I got like did Danny
Glover I'm too old for this or exactly
or yeah it's Morgan Freeman showing up
or they just lean into something it's
just letting the audience know I
appreciate it because I've seen a crap
ton of action movies in my life yeah and
it's sort of like hey we know you're an
action movie fan we're gonna just throw
that little nugget down like the Pinhead
the thing about this movie is because
it's doing it well it's great but most
of its referential stuff is on itself
that's another reason why I'm saying
like again it's not that it's bad it's
just I know what they're trying to do
and they do it very well
they take all the marks yeah they take
all it's a check mark that they did the
check mark and that is it and that is it
and that is great but that is just not a
movie that I gotta be all like we need
you know what I mean like we need to see
maybe it's because I set my expectations
yeah maybe that's why I'm fighting so
hard for is that I set my expectation
that it does check the boxes
this is a great movie it's sad it's a
great movie I think for audiences it's
just what I would call an action movie
crowd pleaser because we've done another
movie on this show that also has a
confusingly low Tomato Meter and a
certainly High audience score and that's
Man on Fire yes with Denzel Washington
and we sort of made our way we were
talking about the like the hard bodies
of the 80s right yeah and then you go
into the Everyman of the 90s and now we
get into this world where we are in
action movies now where it's actually
like the audiences as they age they want
to see the action star age as well which
is why Denzel Washington can still make
those cool equalizer movies Liam Neeson
oh God yeah I will find you okay and you
know what really gave us this sort of
episodic Cinema version of this you want
to know the real thing that cemented
that people say it's die hard but it
wasn't it was 24 because Die Hard was
gone
that sort of brought this sort of like
man against the world episodic nature
again and all of these movies are really
the sons of that and granted it is the
son of Die Hard on television yeah but
just sort of getting audiences back to
that thing that's good I forgot about
you you all just witnessed what happens
on this show way too often I thought I
made a great mic drop point about you
know it was weird the audience ages the
action star ages and then Here Comes
Kohli
and I never equated it that Jack Bauer
pretty much is all of these guys because
again he goes through the same stuff in
one day mind you in one day yes never
eats never has to take a leak he's just
doing his job and by the end of that 24
season yeah like I can't ever do this
again and exactly and we all feel as
exhausted as that so that's a great call
and I that and that's also why you know
the later Innings of that show are
harder for me as well too and I I'll
just stand on that I'm not a this is
what's weird if you showed me this movie
randomly on a Tuesday in 10 years and it
was just separated and I didn't think
about it I'd be like chew it up this is
great let's go but the minute I start to
think about what this movie is like I
basically to your point
oh you're pretty like that's it it's the
girl that you're like you just you be
pretty sweetie and we're gonna have a
good time but I can't think too hard
about this because then it hurts my
brain I feel like Gerard Butler's in
that in that sweet spot with action
movies right now where you have like
your a listers like Tom Cruise doing the
mission Impossibles and whoever's gonna
be playing James Bond next and I heard I
I heard rumors I've heard rumors and
then just but then you don't go all the
way down to like the okay what's outside
7-Eleven at Redbox that I can rent it's
like that right in between you're still
in theaters you're still an action star
you're just coasting you're not like the
777 plane you're just you're a nice 747.
you're coasting at about 20 000 feet
Butler always lands the plane or the
dragon does he though because of the
next movie
you just threw that up and we just
finished like literally it's like you're
like he's just a plane play and I'm like
yeah just like his new movie a plane
plane and it's true because plane comes
out sometime in January this month right
and so whereas you look at somebody
who's like the rock who is gonna have
like the big Fourth of July What Will
Smith used to be like okay we're gonna
have this big action movie and this is
the tempo of the summer Gerard Butler
has January and February and and that's
Liam Neeson territory sometimes too
where it's just like okay early in the
year where we don't want to spend
studios are saying we don't want to
spend too much of our marketing budget
because we got these Oscar movies we
want to push we got these big summer
movies we want to push which is put
these movies out there we know who the
audience is and Jacqueline if they're
like Angel was falling
what's the go-to action okay let's play
this game real quick yeah I will and
then we're gonna get to the we're gonna
get a movie you're at a theater okay and
you're seeing an action movie okay not a
horror movie not a comedy I don't
recommend eating at comedies by the way
no no maybe just have like a soda
um what is your action movie go-to meal
starting with Candace popcorn with
Jalapenos in it you're the only person I
know that has ever done that I love it
you get the box so you get the big bag
you get the box you put the popcorn in
you shake it up with the jalapenos in it
and then if you want to you can if
you're feeling real spicy you get the
nacho cheese you can dip a little bit in
there and then you're gonna have the M
M's peanuts specifically on the side
with the large Diet Coke you added a
little bit more accessories but you know
that this is my thing jalapenos and
popcorn we've done this together we've
had this conversation and I always
thought of you as strange and different
until I was on a plane not the Gerard
Butler movie I was on the real plane and
I was just overhearing these two people
talk about how jalapenos and popcorn is
the best movie theater it's so good and
I yeah I gotta start doing that like I'm
always late to the party putting
anything on popcorn because popcorn is
popcorn yours is good and so I don't
even put butter on it just give me the
popcorn as is but I've recently started
a dabble and put in some M M's some
Reese's Pieces uh Eliza slesiger and
when we go see a movie we'll do uh Sour
Patch Kids oh
she's the one that taught me that trick
and uh I will forever thank her for it
so okay you have now given the so I'm
not your formula but that is my formula
so my formula is the popcorn with the
jalapenos in the bag because AMC is
normally in the bag yeah and then I
shake it and then I take a little bit of
the parmesan that they use for the pizza
or the thingies and I like sprinkle that
on the top give it another little shake
and then I buy The Sour Patch Kids but I
don't put them in the bag okay then you
just keep the spicy and of every about
four handful grab a couple Sour Patch
cool it down and hopefully God willing
your concession stand employee is as
cool as Jason and Corpus Christi Texas
who went viral the way he flips that
popcorn what a hero that guy I hope he's
watching the show yeah that's mine
all over social media the way this guy
is just working the corn oh I gotta
check Jason out because that is my home
theater this is Al is the uh is the
Corpus Christi when I first started
watching stuff good old Corpus Christi
Texas all right that is going to wrap it
up for us on movie talk first much is
like we may have been I divided on the
opinion we got through a lot we got we
did we landed This Plane ladies and
gentlemen so let's go ahead and rip open
the mailbag Brian cue the music
[Music]
okay kids we have a member of the
ketchup crew Philip Calderon he says I
hear oh sorry ketchup ketchup crew
member filled with Calderon here with a
Michael Bay movie request 13 hours oh
we're gonna we're gonna get these men
that are still mad since 2016. it is 51
rotten with an 82 audience score in mine
13 hours is Bay's best movie of the last
decade and my favorite movie of his
personally we need to talk about this
sincerely Philip Calderon I just want to
go and say Philip you did not know the
shots you just fired sir but you have
fired some shots
this is this is your Justice are we
gonna be divided I don't know if we're
gonna be divided but I think this is
your Justice League so I famously when
schmoz know was uh what was was doing
our movie reviews me and Christian I
gave 13 hours 5 out of five shmos uh not
a usual score for me I was blown away by
this movie I thought it was so well done
Michael Bay knows how to do this I wish
he would stick to this kind of stuff
instead of the huge robots fighting each
other my God this movie was awesome and
this is the film if you like that show
Jack Ryan on Amazon this is why you have
Jack Ryan because this is the movie that
turned Jim from the office into a legit
Action Hero when I'm walking into this
movie and I have my you know virgin
popcorn as opposed to being all jalapeno
and Eminem I'm walking in there this is
2016. I was still a baby and I'm sitting
down there I'm watching I'm like how are
they going to make John Krasinski a
badass the very first shot of him in the
Middle East when they get interrogated
and he just put the gun out I'm like oh
I buy whatever this guy's selling yeah
so good to put The Thirst out there
everybody who wondered why Emily Blunt
married uh married him new just watch
that time in that moment we're like oh
that is what was hiding behind you know
why she married him why because she got
to him before I could
well yeah
I Poppins interviews on Rotten Tomatoes
kids you will see me I am trying to come
across the whole thing like her girl all
of you everything just talk to me like
you do in Devil Wears Prada and we will
make it work
[Laughter]
that's a big jump here it's a big jump
but honestly in the quest thirsty
commentary I will make that leap
it is pretty impressive 13 hours 51 it's
sort of man on firing 51 with the
critics 82 of the audience I'm a huge
reason why that audience scores as high
as it is I think we've done all the
Transformers films and there's a new
Transformer film coming out right I
don't know if you're thinking about this
but this might be the moment to give us
some even though it's not a Michael Bay
movie we can give Michael Bay love as
there's another trailer Brian like he's
my parents Brian can we please do three
can we do it please yeah I'm getting the
thumbs up kid so all right keep an eye
out on that Mr Calderon Candace Cruz
thank you again for joining us
entertainment expert for NBC LX thank
you so much ma'am I want to before you
get out of here there's someone in the
know if I tell y'all how many times it
took me to say that correctly I I have
an advanced degree like I have a I have
an advanced
and she watches a lot of 24. but those
those uh those letters really did uh LX
exactly with the jalapenos in it always
exactly uh thank you for joining us
today we don't let you get out of here
as a person in the know without giving
us a recommendation a TV show movie that
you think our audience should be on the
lookout for oh I mean I I humbly want to
brag and plug my own movie that I mean
yes I could do it for you if you want oh
yes please you did see it actually
always well look I caught it the Marina
Del Rey film festival and uh she Stars
along with a friend of the show Roxy
Strayer friend of the show Andrew guys
so it's it really is a wonderful kind of
coming-of-age movie it's got a lot of
Comedy a lot of heart to it and uh some
interesting societal things as well I
will say Candace also got to screen it
in uh in in your hometown recently right
I did which is really cool Kentucky oh
my God that's great it was wonderful and
I had like all my friends and family
come in and just them sitting and
watching it and still cringing at
certain moments that I was kind of
wanting them to cringe at to be like oh
she's gonna do what she gonna do oh oh
um
gym teacher to come watch you exactly I
mean my gym teacher wouldn't because I
very much was not that girl but my choir
teacher would have all my teachers were
there so I had that moment
um so it was very real for me but we
made it into five different film
festivals one three Awards best Ensemble
Best Director best film so really proud
of that and you should be oh my God next
year say the title again always Lola
always Lola you can rent it next year
thank you so much for coming on here
today not at all you should definitely
plug your movie thank you thank you that
is something I would plug everywhere oh
wait this year we're in 2023 now yeah we
are it comes out this year all right
folks we'll be able to rent it this year
uh where can folks find you uh you can
find me on all my social media at
Candace R Crews there it is yeah well
thank you so much for joining us I want
to remind myself again you could also be
like Philip Calderon and email us at RT
is wrong at rottentomatoes.com
because this is gonna cause issues that
might be when we have to bring Christian
in here since he was there was there he
was on the scene with me and I remember
in the video he kind of looked at me
like five out of here
like you want to go I'll I'll put out
the bad signal I'll see if he can uh if
he can leave his house in his uh
wonderful podcasting Empire he has going
on speaking of divisive movies yeah yes
next week we got a bar we have I mean I
don't think this movie necessarily is
divisive but it just it's a polarizing
topic to talk about it is a polarizing
topic it is the live-action film not the
wonderful animated series The live
action The Last Airbender directed by
Eminem he's got to knock in the cabin
which I'm so excited to see coming out
in February and I hope to our power
doesn't have a movie opening against
that because I want I knock at the cabin
to be number one
um and The Last Airbender just that's a
that's a whole discussion that we're
gonna have next week can I do I do I
want to set this like candle light this
candle and walk out the door I do we
watch this together just to get it over
just uh no I've seen it I've seen it too
we might need to re-watch it together
but I will say this
um people are not gonna like my opinion
on this I can't wait I cannot wait for
this I'm excited my last Last Airbender
Defender
oh speaking of Jesus I did see some the
last week that I have to pay off Gerard
Butler in geostorm the one reason why I
loved it Gerard Butler is a is a
legendary world-class scientist who
drinks Coors Light while he's working on
machines
there you go boom that is a great thing
that's a great point I'm glad to pay
that off um again for anyone that heard
what I said about the last Ender bender
and you now don't want to listen to this
podcast come back you never know don't
worry I got you back he probably does uh
but yeah I mean we may I may lose some
fans next week no never thank you for
being here thank you I want to thank you
all for listening we will see you all
net Rotten Tomatoes as
is Brian Perez and everyone here back at
Rotten Tomatoes thank y'all and we'll
see y'all next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]